le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
à la Réunion les hôpitaux et les
cliniques font leur possible pour
répondre à un maximum d'intervention
médicale mais il arrive parfois dans
certains cas particuliers que les
établissements hospitaliers réunionnais
ne possèdent pas l'équipement ou les
compétences adéquats la solution pour
être soignée dans les meilleures
conditions et de partir en métropole le
transfert est bien surpris en charge par
la sécurité sociale mais seulement pour
le malade quand on est hospitalisé le
soutien et les visites des proches
participent à un meilleur rétablissement
mais le voyage et l'hébergement sont
très coûteux c'est donc très difficile
de soutenir un proche hors départements
alors comment avoir le soutien d'un
proche en métropole on en parle
maintenant dans les associations
nathalie est une jeune maman
réunionnaise il y a quelques temps elle
apprend que sa fille est atteint d'une
maladie grave et compliquée à soigner
malheureusement les établissements
hospitaliers de la Réunion n'ont pas les
compétences pour soigner correctement la
maladie de sa fille comme toutes les
mamans le feraient pour leur enfant
Nathalie n'hésite pas une seconde et
fais le nécessaire pour envoyer sa fille
dans un hôpital parisien pour soutenir
sa fille dans cette épreuve difficile
Nathalie part à Paris elle aussi
seulement les billets d'avion et le
logement ne lui permettent pas de rester
le temps qu'il faudrait ce changement de
vie va même jusqu'à la fragiliser elle
aussi
jusqu'au jour où elle apprend que le
conseil général peut l'aider à soutenir
sa fille le temps nécessaire
l'antenne de Paris va alors prendre la
jeune maman rapidement en charge et
faire le nécessaire pour lui permettre
de rester au près de sa fille
depuis elle est hébergée au rosier rouge
une résidence qui accueille les
personnes dans son cas donc il y a des
moments où j'ai failli quand même perdre
la tête on m'a dit parce que on voit ma
fille qui part en opération on est tout
seul ici à Paris parce que c'est vrai au
zéro je connais plein de nom mais tout
le monde voilà qu'on est à l'hôpital on
est tous on est tout seul mais même s'il
y a le corps médical mais on reste quand
même tout seul ça m'apporte on va dire
beaucoup d'amitié on va dire beaucoup de
d'aide aussi mentalement parce que c'est
on est tous dans le même cas voilà ils
ont tout mis en place je pense que le
système est quand même bien organisé à
la Réunion donc avec les assistantes
sociales ils nous guide tout simplement
avec tel organise telle organisme et
puis et eux-mêmes qui font tous les
démarches aussi en même temps à travers
le transfert sanitaire pour l'accueil
ici et puis pour les déroulements de la
maladie voilà concernant le relais ici à
Paris en plus du vol et de l'aide au
logement
Nathalie bénéficie du pack accueil pour
lui permettre de pouvoir circuler dans
la capitale et de téléphoner sans se
retrouver avec des factures
insurmontables le pack d'accueil c'est
il y a le téléphone il y a les tickets
métro et il y a aussi le la carte enfin
il y a un livret où il y a tous les
plans de métro du bus tout ça donc qui
est très utile bon c'est vrai que quand
on arrive on est un peu perdu même si on
a le plan mais voilà après quand on
commence à regarder donc automatiquement
c'était utile et puis surtout les
téléphones donc automatiquement ça ça
nous permet de pas avoir des factures
exorbitantes parce que c'est quand même
un numéro qui reste en métropole
grâce à ce genre de dispositif prise en
charge du billet d'avion pack accueil
aide à l'hébergement aide aux
différentes formalités administratives
le Conseil Général soutient les
Réunionnais dans des circonstances
particulièrement difficiles à surmonter
pour Nassima d'un Dar c'est un devoir
d'apporter du soutien et des solutions à
tous les Réunionnais la maladie est une
épreuve mais quand il faut accompagner
un enfant à pour une opération en
métropole c'est une double épreuve donc
ce dispositif pour aider les
accompagnants des malades parfois pris
en charge par la sécurité sociale était
nécessaire puisque 800 Réunionnais ont
déjà bénéficié de ce dispositif comme
accompagnement du conseil général par
rapport aux malades donc je crois que
cette prise en charge
donne aussi la marque de la solidarité
du conseil général on le dit souvent le
Conseil général aux côtés des
Réunionnais ça n'est pas seulement un
slogan aux côtés ici mais aux côtés
aussi des voyages qu'ils ont à réaliser
dans des épreuves difficiles que la vie
parfois nous réserve comme pour Nathalie
le Conseil Général continue d'aider les
Réunionnais il démontre une volonté
d'être toujours au côté des Réunionnais
car l'accompagnement des malades n'est
pas qu'un des dispositifs facultatifs
mis en place ces dernières années par la
collectivité chaque santé chaque Marmaï
passe transport passes loisirs
l'objectif reste le même permettre à
chaque réunionnais de surmonter ces
difficultés et améliorer le quotidien de
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais